c'est l'homme en forme du moment il a
prouvé sur les greens du golf national
tommy fleetwood 26 ans 4e du dernier us
open a remporté la 101e édition de
l'open de france
pour sa cinquième apparition à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la première
depuis 2010 le fantasque britannique
totalise un score de moins 12 au total
avec une carte de 66 soit cinq coups
sous le par le dimanche je pense que
c'était vraiment important de bien jouer
cette semaine
tout le monde a joué un très bon niveau
pour avoir un bon résultat
le parcours était très agréable et cela
m'a permis d'avoir un swing très
performant un swing qui lui a permis de
devenir le premier anglais remporté
l'open de france depuis 2007 et la
victoire de graines storm
une performance saluée par les milliers
de spectateurs venus pour profiter du
spectacle le dimanche je pense c'est un
joueur dont on entendra beaucoup parler
dans le futur magnifique
super joueur ces nouvelles générations
qui arrivent et ils sont super travers
du côté des tricolores on l'attendait le
meilleur français au classement mondial
alexander levy où l'imprévisible victor
dubuisson
c'est finalement michael lorenzo vera
qui a réalisé la meilleure performance
des bleus sur le parcours de l'albatros
avec un moins huit au total
un score qui lui permet de terminer
troisième du tournoi est de se qualifier
pour le british open une première pour
le basque de 32 ans qui avait du bon
golf bonne attitude voilà toto qui a
bien obtenu une belle partie en plus ce
dimanche avec lee westwood ça c'était
cool santander on joue mary 2 donc ça
fait bien plaisir puisque vraiment là
les gens étaient au repos depuis le
début de la semaine
chaque fois toujours des mots gentils
toujours d amour qu après cette
troisième place michael lorenzo-vera
voudrait succéder à thomas levet l'année
prochaine sur le golf national
le dernier vainqueur français à l'open
de france c'était en 2011
[Applaudissements]